today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that
hitter this past weekend is brought to
you by Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
creators with more than 25,000 classes
and design business and more you'll
cover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity and career take classes and
mobile photography creative writing you
know measuring all types of stuff unique
things on there even illustration you
can't draw yes you can whether you're
looking to discover a new passion or
start a side hustle Skillshare is there
to keep you learning thriving and
reaching those new goals are you a
freelancer try bookkeeping for
freelancers how to handle your finances
one of the most popular courses join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for our listeners this past weekend
listeners get two months AM unlimited
access to over 25,000 classes for free
that's two months of unlimited access to
over 25,000 classes for free go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von to start your two months now let's
see ya lay a fare that means that's that
fare if you see a carnival going on you
say lazy fare that means that's that
fare put some sand on your hands about
time to grip that dolphin you won't have
to fetch that fish baby and we're gonna
do it here today I'll be doing well
[Music]
celebrate
while we celebrate our danes celebrate
our we arranged
I love your demons exercise let them go
[Music]
Oh
and once again can't really fade that
song out as well as I'd like to be you
know I'd love that song at the end to
really just go at a very slow lessening
level so you get less sound in you like
ice like at a gradient they call it and
that's not to be confused with this boy
I used to know named gradient Harper who
used to play on the UH on the local
football team in junior high I remember
we had um a baseball field we played on
and I was on a really rotgut team called
the the Cubs and a couple jerseys they'd
they accidentally wrote clubs on it and
it just so about six of the guys on our
team or on the Cubs that play ville Cubs
and we had about three or four guys on
the play Ville clubs and we would play
on a field out there on the edge of town
off of highway 190 that had a slant it
had a gradient they just I don't know if
you know there had been like uh they
might have been having gravity issues or
something
or I'm not sure this might have been
during a sinkhole flare up I'm not sure
because that sinkholes those things do
when the one that when Mother Earth has
had too much to eat and net [ __ ]
belches somebody's losing a [ __ ] half
a parking lot full of Honda Civics or
something you know they you know she
ain't afraid to digest anything it could
be somebody hitchhiking you know
somebody driving a Dodge Ram everybody
is going straight into the Earth's core
um but we played softball on a on this
field not softball we it was regular
ball baseball and man I wouldn't go to
baseball man I I remember asking the
coach one time if we could put tape on
the ball like rook um you know like uh
duct tape so that thing wouldn't come in
it wouldn't hit you know it wouldn't be
as hard when it hit the glove so most of
baseball was me hiding kind of whenever
the good batters would get up because
I'm a daydreamer I don't need a bed I
don't need a pillow
- you know to really create that
ambience I'm that sir I got that
Spielberg in me I got that cerebral
Spielberg you know I got this [ __ ] is
it's going in my head and so baseball
and a date you can't daydream and do
baseball you cannot you cannot do it
because you're out there and next thing
you know you'll be [ __ ] that ball
comes zinging at you you'll lose an ox
it you know it'll you'll pop your
occipital it hit you and I you when he
got one of your eyeballs roll right out
your mouth like you're a Halloween game
show that [ __ ] can get tricky but we
played on a field when I was on the Cubs
clubs that was at a slant and dude you
would hit a grounder towards first base
and by the time it got to like the
outfield it was oh it was on it was
along the third-base line it was just
every ball so the best player was out
there on third base or in the left field
and I didn't I wasn't good at it man
because I would forget we were playing I
forget I was playing you die Bri I'll be
out there way out in right field picking
stuff and eating it or trying stuff I
mean I wouldn't need I would not eat
everything that I picked that wasn't I
wasn't that boy you know you always had
that one creepy boy just anything he
finally just slid it into his mouth and
it could be anything it's dude you put a
damn snake in his mouth you know some of
these guys they'll babysit a damn you
finally get their jaws open and they're
in there you know they're having you
know a couple little oysters or and
they're doing conjugal visits and stuff
some people will put anything under
their tongue
oh but that field man it was so hard
because if a ball went into the outfield
and you got it you had to run you had to
run uphill it was very I mean it was
like a damn decathlon just trying to get
the ball in and sometimes you would
throw it and it would come right back
down the hill at 2 you're like gee well
and then at the far left field it went
sloped that way it sloped out the one
guy hit it this one fella Mikey Donnell
war and he was my god this guy he was on
I mean he must have came out of the womb
with a uh you know he must have came out
of the womb with a damn with capability
and capability is when you just when
you're not you know when you just when
you can do something have you ever done
anything
well that's capability right there and
this boy just had all the athletic
capability and he would hit that ball
and we went to get it it went over the
deep off the edge deep field and dude it
took you sometimes I remember getting a
ball and coming up the hill off the deep
end and by the time I got up there the
game had been over for about 40 minutes
everybody just knuckle deep eating snow
cones and some of the parents are over
there
you know you know complaining about
their spouses or whatever some of this
one lady would cry every time we won
like [ __ ] you're not even gonna have a
kid on the team okay you just out here
lurk and I said list lady would creep us
out dude she'd be crying somebody would
hit a damn double and she would start
crying I'm like jeepers and she had a
Don Mattingly tattoo on her [ __ ] on
her ribs but she was beautiful though I
will say that she had a certain beauty
about her you know there's something
there's something very American about it
when somebody hits a damn double you
know and a lady starts crying just a few
feet away there's something hell I don't
even know it's almost like it's like
that movie uh it's the way I feel when
I'm when I watch that movie Cinderella
man my heaven nothing [ __ ] get me bro
Cinderella man what's going on good to
see you happy November 18 and it is the
year 2019 to zero one nine and we are
living it we are living through time I
was thinking about that this weekend how
time is just such a it won't you can't
stop it I mean you just
it's on it's just uh it's kind of like
the it's the LeBron James of mediums
this [ __ ] is going and sometimes I
realize I'm like hey time time time you
know I'm over here you know hold it up
but timing [ __ ] with you boy timing
[ __ ] with you you little [ __ ] out
here on that lopsided field get your
[ __ ] together I can't believe our town
would do all of that just really and
they had regular fields I think they had
a couple parents out there like seeing
the children struggle and seeing you'd
have some kids do they play baseball so
much they'd have a dam they would grow
into genetic leave and one of their legs
almost had a little bit more reach on it
they'd be a little bit more right legged
or you'd see some of the coaches out
there would measure that right leg on
you during practices and stuff because
see who would be able to get the best
angles based on the field and that was
it's weird when carpentry kind of comes
into a baseball you know when somebody
when you got a damn subcontractor out
there
playing on the you know as a third-base
coach it just gets a little kind of
obtuse oh it is it is November what's
going on with you I hope you're well
today I'm feeling okay I'm feeling okay
man I'm feeling like I'm this past week
I've been really motivated to just get
to the gym and get that pump get that
body pump and the other day I even taped
off my legs but a tight tape and tape is
something that's basically for people
that's too lazy to get it rope and do
something they made tape so it's really
just kind of [ __ ] rope and boy I'll
tape these thighs closed and I keep my
blood up top because when I needed one I
used to do that if I would do a test or
something or you know in school man I've
always had a hard test dude you know I'd
have my both my legs tied off bro ain't
letting my blood go down to my feet and
do what think about what slippers
I need my blood up top I need my
knowledge bubbling through my freakin
little brain tank cuz you got to keep
the water warm up there you know all
these at your extremities a lot of times
they're wasting time you put you I want
that straight when I'm under pressure I
want heart to brain heart to brain I
don't want that you know your Bloods out
here hitchhiking and you're damn you
know that fourth finger the one you can
barely get straight even when if you try
to make it straight by itself you know
the one I don't care if that [ __ ] ever
gets any blood honestly I want the blood
where I need it so you'd see me in a
test my arms and leg be turning purple
and some of the kids you like - you all
right man you can't even hold your
pencil black [ __ ] I'm doing social
studies okay and I'm trying to get a B
so I'm living what I'm try gotta do
something for myself here this
preservation and you guys out here doing
that full flow I'm going brain no hard
boy and I'm living like that what's
going on I'll do a little bit of laundry
we have we still want some single
mothers for sure Lafayette and that
shows almost sold out down there
December 26th so we'd love that if you
want to call and recommend one or two we
have the show in December 10th at The
Wiltern in Los Angeles that's almost
sold out we just put on Red Bank New
Jersey which is the makeup show for
sales Vil it's now at a bigger locale so
you can get in there and sit down and
and feel that feel your body in the
chair and there's something nice about
that when you when your body hits a
chair there's something I mean they
perfected that you know what chair they
as such a perfectional piece say hey hey
come here stay right here with me
and you do it
time you see a chair you do it not
beautiful a chair is like hey I'll be
over here do what you do but you know
where I'll be at and you get over there
and you put your ass right on it
chairs a dirty man paints they're gonna
get pinkeye they keep playing all these
games oh okay what's going on with with
you who's listening out there I wonder
who's listening sometimes and I wonder
who isn't I know we have a young lady
named Amanda who is a long time er
listener Thank You Amanda and I'm gonna
give her a call now and just see who
listens to this thing she's a
correctional officer so I've been around
some seedy men around
hey Amanda what's up is he oh hi how are
you I'm doing well how are you today I'm
good thanks
and you you've listened now you've
listened to most of this past weekend
yes yeah
I've listened to all of them okay and
how are you doing I'm good yes nice I'm
just making sure you're holding up okay
I think so yeah okay good and you're a
correctional officer right I am working
Corrections I do admin at jail and what
is it like over there are people is it
kind of like you see on Shawshank
Redemption where people are you know
kind of like dirty but also hopeful or
what's the vibe you think Oh sometimes
yeah we get a lot of you know people
fresh off the street because we're a
County Jail so they haven't been
sentenced or anything they come to us
you know please pick them up straight
off the street
bring them to us so we see all kinds of
people you know mentally unstable you
know people who people who are currently
on drugs and you've brought in hi Wow um
duis people who are currently Bronx who
have to you know stay and be hawks and
sleep it off and do they team up do they
put them on teams those are like a team
room where there's more than one man in
there or is it there it is everybody
gets their own room holding well know
when you first come in to be processed
pretty much everyone is in the same
little holding cells
yes that's almost like American Idol or
something I would hate that it's like
backstage at on at American Idol yeah
and you know it's it's interesting to
say the least because you know you have
some that are aggressive and wanna you
know shadowbox with themselves other
people and then you have you know people
who are drunk and they just want to
sleep so you get a whole mix of
different people and does it get pretty
does it get kind of homoerotic at that
point or that's later in this system I'm
wonder if you're seeing any of that no
I'm holding but you know that does
happen when they get to their to their
housing oh yeah you hold it for long
enough you want to put it in something
you know and that's but yeah you're just
in holding so one more question I have
or do you find that so you these people
so now so your job exactly so you're not
escorting them back there with a weapon
or anything like that you're not doing
any of that correct
no I I do an admin side like a Monday
through Friday hmm so after they come in
and they're processed and they go to
their tank I coordinate programs so if
they want to go to church or a a GED
that sort of thing nice um yeah I do the
secure system which is our phone system
so selling phone cards that they had any
issues with their phone accounts things
like that their money their money system
if their family has an issue putting
money on to their commissary account you
know I'm the person that they would talk
to you to try to resolve their issues I
see and are most of them do you find
like a lot of the inmates are pretty
friendly for you towards you does it
vary or at their
is there a general kind of vibe amongst
inmates well because I tried to because
you know innocent until proven guilty a
lot of them there hadn't been the court
so I try to treat people with respect as
long as they respect me and that seems
you know they're really receptive to
that so yeah being a female in
Corrections is tough whether you you
know are an officer bad man
doesn't matter yeah oh I can totally
imagine and do a lot of the men come
over there and kind of perv out by you
do you have anybody you know doing you
know sending you little handfuls of
dirty stuff from their body or anything
or what is it what do you get do you get
any gift definitely why no I get notes I
get lots of no and what are you looking
for a date or is it are they thinking is
it what are they looking for a date a
couple yeah when I get out I'm gonna
find you okay find me first of all
find me ain't the best way to pick a
woman up you know what I'm saying mr.
criminal you hear a criminal
that ain't my pickup line especially if
I'm a criminal we'll find you no one
knows who I am or where I live but
they're gonna come find me do they get
have you ever engaged with an inmate um
no just in no just one-on-one you know
they have a question about something
answer it but other than that I try not
to learn too much their lives why
they're there yeah because it doesn't
matter to me why you're there hmm you
know just be respectful to me I'll be
respectful to you I see I love it
and is it it you feel like it's a tough
job for a woman do you feel like is it a
man's world
is it a man's world in the end the
prison system I think that men they get
more respect they get a lot more respect
whereas a female a lot of them see you
as weak or you know or maybe that they
can that they can try to talk you into
doing something for all so I think it
takes a special part
do a lot of them try to get druid a see
the woman at the low hung fruit do they
do they try to get drugs in do they try
to get bait you know playing cards or
you know like whistle or anything like
anything unique that they're trying to
get in there you're asking you oh not me
personally I've never encountered that
but I've heard of instances yes where
they try to make friends and they say
hey you know we're friends bring in the
pack cigarette there you know but me
personally I don't wanna get involved yo
and that I don't have to Constance erect
contact with them like like an actual
corrections officer would ya I don't see
them every second of my shift
I see so I think that's where I have an
advantage because my contact is brief
yeah so it's brief and if you are is
there a lot of handsome men going into
prison or what style of man is it
visually no no it may be maybe it's be
drugs maybe you know maybe at one time
they were handsome but you know where I
work I haven't seen anyone in particular
that was too handsome
a lot of four and five a lot of four and
five doing crime huh it may be even
threes there's a lot of threes and you
got to earn a three man because that
lower gives you five man you got to earn
a three well you know when you have two
teeth yeah that's hard but when you got
to man you got this year you got to take
care of those babies at that point
that's not even a smile that's just pets
those are just pets in your mouth you
know you got to take care of them all
right well thank you so much for
listening I really appreciate it and uh
and I just wanted to say thank you yeah
no problem
I enjoy it and if I go to jail I hope I
see you definitely yep definitely whoa
okay well I just want a deck of cards
that's what all I want with some
pictures on the best nudie pics you know
well regular cards I can give some Ofcom
theory but I don't know about the nudie
one well maybe I'll just draw those on
my own there myself to make them yeah
you have to make
find someone who's really good oh okay
you know prison art is prison arts the
best they can they really have figured
out how to you know draw a really good
nipple oh really now do you see a lot of
that do they confiscate a lot of that
people drawn titty and drawn all of that
you can draw it um you know you can send
it out I've seen it I've seen it a lot
of it hey now
amen oh thank you so much Amanda and I
hope you have a great hope you have a
great week of it air I appreciate it
thank you so much all right said I'll
talk to you soon
all right okay bye bye right and that's
Amanda right there and thank you very
much Amanda for listening and she made a
list this is how I found her number she
made a list of all the people that I've
ever talked about from my hometown and
sent it to us as like a glossary and a
glossary is you know it's a list and you
know that don't you you should we all
should I gotta pay the bills real quick
today's episode is brought to you by
candid you know it's that time of year
it's that time of year when a reindeer
might just fly right past your house
looking for a hot gram it's that time of
year to share smiles and good times with
friends and family this is time to
tickle your damn uncle boy and hide your
cousin and then damn a dirty clothes
hamper hot is a little ass and of course
it's time to exchange gifts how about
you give yourself a gift like I'm doing
today give the gift of self-confidence
now how'd you get it how do you get that
self-confidence by having straighter
brighter teeth will will help and that
is from candid candid aligners can
straighten your teeth faster and cheaper
than traditional wild braces or wire
braces some people call them treatment
takes just six months on average and
cost 65 percent less I mean think about
that think about getting that grill
you'll be a grill Rilla baby you'll be
in the zoo
you'll be the to do of the zoo when you
get that grill tight tight tight I'm
Yuka Smyth you smile harder you [ __ ] I
have a fine are damn diamond under your
tongue what I'm talking about sheer
beauty an experienced orthodontist to
his license in your state creates a
custom treatment plan they show you a 3d
preview you can see how your teeth will
look after you're done so you get to see
the progress plus in this season of
giving candid donates $25 with each
aligner purchased to smile train who
brings a hundred percent free cleft lip
and palate treatments to children around
the globe
I guess via train I guess which is
pretty cool you know it's beautiful to
think that they're they're about a
station and that train comes in and has
those aligners on it give yourself the
gift of candid go to candid co.com slash
Theo and use code Theo to get $75 off
$75 off that glisten and grill that's
candid co.com slash Theo code Theo for
$75 off candid letter C letter o dot-com
slash Theo code Theo and look snitches
get breeches so I got to tell you about
me undies look it's the holidays and if
you've never had them which I don't know
how you couldn't have but if you've
never had them I mean you want to talk
about a stocking stuffer stuff yourself
into a pair of me undies and you will
just feel stocked up to the gills with
Joey me undies is anything but ordinary
they have a gift for literally everyone
yes including your weird aunt that you
know she'll be she could whistle and
then pull up half a handful of black
olives out of her mouth that's Italian
and the best part is me undies delivered
straight to your door
with free shipping and that's a miracle
look I've had them on I've worn my I've
warned me on these before before a party
I've worn them after a party
so you could just tell you right there
was a pretty damn good party look me
undies makes the perfect hibernation
undies and loungewear if you don't want
to go out me on these knows that it's
getting cold in a lot of places this
year and they're coming out with even
more cuddly products you can cozy up
with new robes for men and women and
Game of Thrones fans or you can treat
yourself in those soft new slippery's of
slippery slippers sorry and they grip at
the bottom so you won't be slippery and
you can match the whole family imagine
your whole damn family wearing the same
thing and going to a damn Chevron or
something to get one of those hot ah
chicken biscuits with brand new holiday
prints and cozy products me undies has a
gift for literally everyone it's a great
time for our listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 15% off in
free shipping this is a no-brainer
because they have a hundred percent
satisfaction me undies dot-com slash
weekend to get your 15 percent off your
first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction
go to me undies dot-com slash weekend I
love them and you will thank you guys
good to see you good to hear you what's
going on being alive you know making it
through the year I'm kind of amazed how
time goes so fast you know I was
brushing on it a little earlier I mean
time time just it's like the fastest
friend you have it and you're always
like come here buddy and times life
and sometimes I find I even get angry at
time in my brain I'm like time shut it
down guy you're not trying to tighten up
over here and you keep just making me
feel loose because you keep just time is
that guy like when you go on rappelling
and he just keeps throwing rope out
there you know like your boy Larry time
he just roping you out but that's life
man that's life it says that limited
time offer you know life is that limited
time offer where it's just it's so it's
the only show in town that's the thing
for as much as we know it's the only
show in town and so we got to grab this
bastard because this is it when we're
doing it we're doing it man we're doing
it I'm back on that Hope bus
all aboard this bus is short but it's
hopeful Sun gang yeah we had some great
calls that came in what I do this
weekend oh I did this breathing work
thing it's called Breath of Fire you
could look it up online and it's where
you it's where you inhale like a bunch
through your nose and then you hold your
breath and you got a saw
eating up that little dirt dimple that
kind of TA int I don't want to say it
out loud but you know that ta int area
of your body you know that little
isthmus between your nuts and your
little back jaw you know down there in a
stink Ganis tan brother area right
between your nuts and your little bee
holy oh well you tighten that up and you
hold your breath after you do all that
breathing and you're supposed to catch a
little bit of a free buzz and it's
called
fire Bri [ __ ] on what's called but you
do it in the morning and it really helps
you out and you can look it up and I met
a man this man had like a this man his
name is um Casey no Henry no Herman no
um his name was Randy no breathing let
me see what his name is real quick to
him nice man - I wish I wouldn't forget
his name right now breathe breathing
Troy Casey that's his man that's his
name and uh which is crazy I knew if a
kid growing up this boy Troy Casey
Walter and he had three first names no
last names and um man you're [ __ ]
really if that happens but this man only
has two his name's Troy Casey and he was
really cool and and when you do that and
you do this fire-breathing technique you
activate the DMT that's in your body and
it's that free you know it's just like
the Lord put that lollipop right into
you and you're like you know you first
year was Lalli him but now you pop in
I'm a sucker for a sucker and I'll put a
link to one of his videos and it was
really it got me feeling just I just
started to feel a little bit more gifted
and it made me feel a little more
motivated so I'm happy that I've just
been running a lot this past week and
I'm hopeful that I'll keep doing that
yeah just you know it's just it's time
to just this whole year for me and I
know I said all the time has just been
very I don't maybe I shared all the time
and it's all I share but it's been
really tough this year has been very
tough for me which it's hard to complain
because I've had such a progressive year
with work and it's hard to complain but
and I don't want to I don't want to
complain I just want to stay focused on
feeling good and and I can do it I can
do it I've done a lot and I can do this
so that's what I'm telling myself today
we have some calls that came in as
always on the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three also
Oh what did I do this past the past two
weeks we did a campaign for Sam Adams
and that'll be you'll get to see it it's
a video and I don't drink but the
campaign is really amazing and you don't
have to drink to do the campaign which
was which I thought was pretty cool but
and which is also the only way that I
would do it but they it was about
toasting somebody you know like toasting
you know where you really say hey you
know you're my buddy or you know cheers
to you and it was uh you'll see it
there's gonna be some other of your
favorite podcast people in there or not
favorite I mean you may listen to this
and can't stand me but there's going to
be out just a tribe of of podcast people
that are doing these um toast
someone campaigns and that happy hitter
oh and Toronto is is gonna finally go on
sale this week so and the Braille we're
gonna make those dates up I don't know
when but it's going to happen probably
March so onward here we go yo see oh
it's mornin out here
and st. Louis man mornin and that's a
great name and that's an I mean that's
obviously a name you got to use before
noon and uh and that's got to be great
because it's got to be just peaceful
after that nobody bothering you
onward brother I would just pin you up
cuz are you talking about that ice cream
machine in McDonald's man I used to work
up there they canned me and I'll say the
truth about that thing man it's always
working it's just nobody wants to clean
it so they just tell you it's broken all
the time if you want some ice cream
you want to get that sundae you just
tell them straight up look imma talk to
your district manager I know that thing
works
and I guarantee you man don't fire that
boy up for you but then you got to be
careful because they probably going to
spit in it mmm so remember that the next
time you hit a late night McDonald's
don't let them pull that [ __ ] on you
gang okay they always do it and how much
spit that's the question it really pops
into your brain like a like a damn
vulture with a handful of you know warm
marbles I mean that's the thing this you
know how much you know if they drop one
little you know about a 19th of an ounce
or something over to the edge I can
handle it boy but if they do all you
know if they clear the throat I'm out
well yeah that's the thing McDonald's I
mean here's the thing this is a great
time for McDonald's to finally fire up
the the ice cream machines all these
[ __ ] can't be off all of them can't
be off McDonald's are getting lazy they
fighting at Popeye's Chicken they got
peace but every now and then somebody
gets choked out over there angry about
the Lord
Roche I'm telling you it's all turning
into the WWE and it's beautiful it's
beautiful
[Music]
you can have everybody next thing you
know it's gonna be you know Krusty the
crab is gonna be running for office
you're gonna have a someone's gonna give
birth to a damn watermelon it's all
merging This Is It this is the time this
is the time for somebody to just pull
the damn reach in here reach into your
do you can this is a Tommy you could do
all kind of stuff anything do what
somebody do a backflip off a damn
Wendy's kids are learning baseball on
slanted fields okay it's a new era where
anything is possible
and we got it and I'm happy to be here
with you doing it all right let's take
another call good luck out there man
yeah I'm gonna tell them I'm a
threatened that district manager imma
hit him with that slide in the DM okay
cuz I know they they got that Sunday
superintendent and he's he knows that I
scream switch and I roll up every time I
said damn which an hour is broke oh we
can't get it to uh turn it on jack
okay I'm sorry sorry we out on our arm
turn it on
I want the Sunday and I want the little
second nutty nuts with it okay then
little freakin little bitty damn look
like you could barely get them stuck in
your teeth them little nut nuggets I
want though I want to packs it in
[ __ ] and I want it all or nothing at
all
turn on the sundae maker y'all in there
laughs and thinking you just all you
gonna make all night is little
cheeseburgers and this and that I want
six happy meals boy I wanna [ __ ] I
know what y'all doing in there
y'all back there hiding [ __ ] eating
them nighttime it griddles being risky
well look here grimace the Menace turn
it on turn on the sundae maker people
driving across town to get a damn sweet
cold frozen icy nighttime cupped snack
and you've got the audacity to just but
I don't oh it's all I'm sorry to tell
you but no I'm sorry to tell you but
I'll draw it Popeyes Chicken sandwich on
the wallet is fraggin McDaniels and rays
straight h-e-l-l-o aang bruh turn it on
I'm sorry man it's just makes me mad boy
it makes me mad so that's that first
call right there and that's the truth if
you want the facts you threaten that
district manager I'm about to slide in
here DM all right gang let's go right
here we got another call as always nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three yo Co is Gary from Pennsylvania
what's up Gary oh hey Gary hey Gary
hey hey Gary hey Gary you know I thought
when I was young I thought my name was
Gary for a little while because somebody
lied to me but I told myself I forgot
that it was me that it told myself that
and that crazy let's hear more okay you
know just I'm listening to you're one of
the latest podcast and I'm some dudes
call about El Chapo being down in the
Sinaloa you know no there was a Sinaloa
cartel oh yeah that's down there with
that animal sanctuary I was trying to
get in with and I haven't heard from
that guy I mean that's the only thing
I'm not gonna invest if I can't even get
a text back from the guy hope he's all
right homework and
I have to agree with him and I don't
think this is a good investment just I
the last two weeks though Chapel son was
kidnapped and his whole cartel so try to
sit the whole city on fire you know
obviously you're not an investment or
anything but I would recommend against
your honest opinion well look man I feel
you thank you I want to say that thank
you very much
the only thing I'm thinking look if
they're burning if they're burning
property you know what's running out of
the fire any malice okay penguins
Yaffe's burrows parrots Falcons perros
Gatos pescado um I don't matter deals so
I'm talking about getting free uh I'm
taking off getting you know stocking at
my warehouse for free if they're down on
it burning it down so you got to think
reverse psychology so now I'm gonna come
to an investment but but I appreciate it
man let's hear a little bit more I mean
to shut you off there brother but I just
don't want to see you this world over
and that [ __ ] is on fire yeah but fine I
mean here's the thing dude after fire
comes a lot of beauty think about the
Big Bang Theory think about that think
about that song fire on the mountain you
get a mountain think about let's hear
more from your amount of ideas on it I
think you do better and it doesn't look
really good like good well I'm not even
trying to they're not even trying to go
outside recently so just be careful what
you do then gang bruh muchas gracias
Senora and I do appreciate that it's
very sweet of you to call especially you
know probably having a little bit more
of an Intel to the to the deal
yeah it's $4,500 to get in on a zoo down
there
and here's the tempting thing I've
always wanted to own a zoo though I
don't think there's a man out there that
doesn't want to have a that have a
little bit of Tarzan in their nuts
you know you lift up my arm meet us here
oh you know I got everybody's got that
thing that that beast in them I got that
Beast infection and I you know just
thinking about just being at night and
just having a unicorn outside or not a
unicorn us but having a you know a um
you know an exotic horse with nice hair
think about that imagine a horse that's
just [ __ ] been cornrowed its whole
body nobody's doing that that's what we
do with the Mexicans ooh la zoológico
they may go
so I'm saying forty five hundred to get
in on a you know on a Sinaloa and zoo
that's it sounds it doesn't sound like
much I'm saying you're talking about
some real serious animals you're talking
about a South American Eagle think about
that [ __ ] boy you know what I'm saying
dude he's gonna be bald he's gonna had
that deuce bro he's gonna have [ __ ]
one of his claws real sharp that I'm
just saying man you're gonna have some
really exotic animals at that zoo you
gonna have a giraffe dude maybe in a arm
but he gots all kind of neck tats think
about that ms-13 ms 14 ms 15 ms 16 and
all the way on through you know till he
graduated high school so there's just
the possibilities are endless on the
type of animals you could have in a
Mexican Zoo you have to think about it
all I appreciate you though brother and
thank you man thanks for calling in it's
nice of you
alright let's take a call a question
actually patreon Matt Nichols
where is raising cane's on the Popeyes
chick-fil-a continuum you ever flirted
with a Zach's piece and I have I've had
a little bit of Zaxby's over there
that's how I think I don't know if it's
out of Nashville but it's their version
of a Popeye's or it's chicken fingers
and I when I was young you had to go get
the [ __ ] was on the bone
these you know these youngsters they got
it so easy with the chicken fingers well
you know safe chicken that's really what
that is then when I was young you had to
take a risk on you don't know what that
was you could be having a femur you
could be having a damn scapula you
didn't know what was under the breading
but you got chicken and you got bone
guaranteed and you had to get through
that [ __ ] you still have to get a little
freaking off you had to get [ __ ]
immortal with that [ __ ] and it meant now
you know you can just look now you know
you could fall asleep with two chicken
fingers in your mouth you wake up fine
week back in the day you had to take a
chance every time you got the chicken
here to take a damn a chicken chance and
they got these easy ass buckets make it
through a [ __ ] five piece you got it
you drinking a 40 right there maybe you
got a freaking couple you know you doing
half a gram with your cousin y'all
[ __ ] trying to get through a
five-piece with bones now we talking
teamwork son now we talking real men
what are we talking about here let's
take this call here we go yo Chuck big
Chuck oh wait sorry I forgot this
question I'll say this about raising
cane's and I believe it's want to say
it's a Louisiana company raising cane's
I like their chicken fingers if you go
I like the toast they got the toast boy
dude when I die bury me in sighs another
toast they got that toast
sometime the toast tastes better than a
damn chicken I'm like what's in the
what's in the toast better chicken it's
good so here's the thing if you get a
mass order this is when they failed they
all fail I find when you get a mass
order you get 200 of those fingers and
then [ __ ] show up drooping the
[ __ ] looking like they got arthritis
in there
my buddy found a [ __ ] middle for a
real middle finger and a whole thing of
fingers and damn it and that's [ __ ]
just good luck that's almost Irish
that's almost Scottish but yeah you got
a really uh you got a really want to
order that 200 piece and they get that
as don't do them as well and that's
everything it gets to be a lot it's the
the consistency isn't as valuable to the
creator you know the first piece you get
that's that work art and after that is
that work of effort and that's where uh
where things fall apart sometimes is
when you get away from the work of art
and you went and things become a work of
effort and that's what I find but I go
honestly if I had to really rank them
out and Poppi's the biscuits are so good
I wouldn't get I mean just regular
biscuits I don't care if they got
chicken in them or not I like a sausage
biscuit from McDaniels over there and
they got them it dude in the morning I
take the sausage off put it on the side
I jelly
each side of the biscuit then I had that
sausage on the sonic a little steak like
a little baby morning State
and I'll cut into that first biscuit and
have that [ __ ] you know because that's
almost like a little freaking pie when
you look at it and especially if you you
know kind of crimp the edges of it with
your fingers like a pie is and then I'll
have a little bit of that steak that
frickin morning State and then I
finished off with that [ __ ] baby
dessert the second half of that biscuit
but that's you know for me that happens
in the airport a lot I'll get that
hitter but yeah I'll do a Zacks because
I haven't had enough Zach's piece but
I'm willing to do more and but Popeyes
man that's the one if you're gonna get
murdered Brooke go to pawpaws that's the
one you want to die yet ain't [ __ ]
dying outside of a Burger King bro you
can miss me with that [ __ ] oh man here
we go we had another call that came in
Oh weird oh wait uh here we go yo truck
Mississippi taxidermy buddy listen I was
just thinking about you Lulu project
What's Up Chuck do ya Chuck man what's
going on oh you're calling about the zoo
too Chuck sent me a whole bunch of
beautiful thing a meat elk and
everything elk um [ __ ] I don't know what
all's in there dude I've had a couple
pieces of it it is tangy let's hear more
thanks Chuck I think it's a winner dude
get that zoo
I'll come out under the taxidermy get
here on those animals you want me not to
feed them no more man people just calm
have them nice all opposed uh listen I
think it's a winner I'm gonna go ahead
and order some materials you get after
you got my novel brother Oh deal we
don't have the funds from material yet
man we still dealing with the
preliminary ordeals we're still
gentlement the first you know potential
war deals brother and you got to make it
through potential ordeals Bay before you
get into the secondary level which is
what you're trying to be it
but I don't that's not a bad idea maybe
taxidermy zoo and Matco like almost like
a Ripley's Believe It or Not but for
animals and dude some of the animals
could even have a gunshot or something
mental you know you see a [ __ ]
largemouth bass out there with two
[ __ ] slugs under its fan you're like
damn there's more than one way to cook a
fish gang brother thanks for calling
Chuck man I miss you dog I'll text you
thanks for the beautiful amount of meat
you sent me shear God if it was you I
think it was you that sent it man thank
you very much
so me and Chuck what did we do one day
we went and did something where was in
Louisiana and I feel bad man my brain
just it's not holding as much water as
it did might take next week off might
take next week off so if there's not an
episode just know that it's nothing
personal just trying to relax man trying
to relax uh let's take another call here
we go actually I got to tell you about
this right here and you got to know it
and that is that hiring hiring can be a
slow process Cafe alturas CEO Oh Dylan
miss go it's miss Coe it's needed to
hire a director of coffee for his
organic coffee company but he was having
trouble finding qualified applicants so
he switched to zip recruiter zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience and invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates immediately you need these
candidates
you can't give a job as somebody that's
not a candidate you walk up to somebody
on the street and say hey we need you
right now in the courtroom and they're
like [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] electrician you
can't do it like that
Dylan posted his job on zip recruiter
and said he was impressed by how quickly
he had great candidates apply he also
used zip recruiters candidate rating
feature to filter his applicants so get
rid of those you know I'm saying you
looking somebody for somebody to do lawn
care and you know this dude said he does
for you know breastfeed in the long way
you could filter him out immediately and
that's how Ilyn find his new director of
coffee in just a few days with results
like that it's no wonder four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day see why zip recruiters effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free at our web address
zip recruiter dot-com slash tpw try it
out you need an employee you need a good
one try out zip recruiter comm slash tpw
the smartest way to hire oh man that's
beautiful
and this I gotta let you know that my
sister doesn't even know this what she's
getting for Christmas and I need some of
this made me set a time my legs off you
get these figs nurses doctors dentists
and people who work in medicine and
healthcare are pretty awesome we all
agree on that
and all of us can think of a time when a
medical professional helped us or a
family member they're helping they're
helping us for years nurses doctors
dentists and other awesome
medical professionals were forced to
wear scratchy ill-fitting scrubs if you
look at old pictures you'll see them in
burlap out there sometimes even just
rope wrapped around their body while
they're trying to put a put an IV or you
know tie off a colostomy not only were
they ugly and uncomfortable but they
weren't designed with innovative
technical properties to protect you and
hold life-saving tools figs care is also
every time you shop at figs they give
scrubs to a health care provider in need
around the world through their threads
for threads initiative
figs gift cards are available so next
time you're a friend who's a doctor
nurse dentist dermatologist pediatrician
or some just somebody who likes some
damn roleplay at least look like you
have a job during sex tell them thank
you by sending them figs so if you're an
awesome human that works in health care
someone that wants to say thanks to
these deserving folks figs is gonna make
that easy by providing you with 15% off
your first purchase by using my code th
e Oh get ready to love your scrubs head
to where figs dot-com WEA are f IG s
calm and enter my code Theo at checkout
my sister will be getting those Rolanda
that's my sister's name and she's going
to get those for Christmas course she's
getting a couple of free passes to that
sinaloa zoo dog you know what I'm saying
somebody needs you to teach an antelope
how to use an ay k boys shits popping
off down there let's get into let's take
one more call and then maybe we'll get
Nick in and go over some news here we go
hey Theo my name is L I live in the Los
Angeles area
hey L thank you for calling and that's
what these day people have a simple name
l or you know em home word so I've been
doing improv the last two years and
there was this guy that I noticed in
another class night I needed me to loved
him and if I was attractive and
eventually I started my own sketch group
and I did invite this person you know
he's funny but I also you know loved him
yeah you got sex on the head you got it
you got a sex head a little lady more I
found out later that he does have a
girlfriend
and it's every week and each week it
gets a little bit harder to be around
them because you know I really
um I really like him and so if you think
the advice please let me know buddy
thank you
well it's beautiful that you uh that you
care about somebody that's good it's
nice that you do that some people never
care about anybody they walk somebody be
on fire they walk right past I'm having
a soda and just keep drinking a soda
[ __ ] put them out that's a day do to
half a dr. pepper will save somebody
probably from the waist down but so what
I'm saying is that yeah I mean that kind
of sucker you invited a man and now you
got him there you know what I'm saying
if you bring the cat to the cradle you
can't you're gonna have to hear him meow
whether you guys are [ __ ] or not or
doing sex or not hmm I think you just
got to be because at this point if he
was interested in being not you know
getting you know if he was interested in
really playing two-hand touch without
any hands and just with penis and
everything but then he would he would be
on it you know and I've been a dirt ball
so I don't really you know I know if he
were really interested he would probably
have been on it and if you got him in
there every week you throwing it at him
you know The Improv and you telling him
oh why don't you come over here and you
know you know pretend my uh you know
pretend my butt's on fire and you're a
jouster
and he's like well how does that make
any sense it's like oh you just come on
you'll see run in run in with your jowl
stir yeah I don't know I really can't
help that situation that's you know is
just your it just kind of sucks kind of
sucks there because [ __ ] dude so many
times you invite people to do something
you want to have sex with them they
don't and you just can't have sex with
them it's illegal to continue to try to
do it
I mean you can try but did you know you
can't there's no way to make it happen
you know without magic or doing
something real I mean here's the thing
man my stepdad and it's not my real
stepdad but there's a this family I got
a you know emancipated when I was young
and I went live with a family in high
school and the man is kind of like my
stepdad and I call him that anyway
because it just is more comfortable but
he told me when he was in just I don't
know when he wasn't something alive when
he was alive and younger that he went to
he had a girlfriend and she got they
broke up and then she got engaged like a
couple months like maybe six eight
months a year later and one night he was
drinking and he just thought he was
still in love with her he went over to
her house and proposed he said hey look
I still love you and this I'm the right
guy for you and she said she said no and
he said he was happy because the next
day he realized that he was just drunk
but so anyway what I'm saying is it's
okay to take your chances it's okay to
put the feelers out there but if they're
really in love and they got a happy deal
going on you know you don't want to you
know you don't want to you know piss
loudly into a baby's crib so but good
luck out there and and thanks for
helping I wish I could help I can't help
I cannot help
let's get Nick in here real quick man I
got to hit a meeting but thank you guys
so much for being here
we're gonna do some news with Nick and
then we will and then we'll get to the
end and and that's it that's it all
right we got the news here Nick what's
up man what's going on man how you doing
I'm doing all right bro thank you for
asking you um you had a good weekend I
heard you say earlier when I came in
what was up yeah it was fun Friday just
met up with some friends and played
tennis for a couple hours and then we
went out to the bars after
hmm and Saturday just watch the UFC and
then I went to the concert or went to a
concert with the girl that I went to
Logan Paul fight with oh yeah
2nd round huh yep yep I saw Lee fields
sold soul singer he's like kind of James
Brown s cat museum Museum of
Contemporary Art and yes I'll weekend
all around
dang dude get gambled gambling went
really well
yeah that's really you said you hit a
four cut for hit for hit uh thing parlay
yeah for hit parlay it was yeah fifty to
win five hundred not bad ten times to
return I'll take it damn he'll take it
he'll take it man what do we got for the
news dude that second date though how
was that it was good it was chill it's
very easy she's fun
Wow yeah yeah let me try and guess her
name can I guess her first name I doubt
it but okay that's kind of a hint um
that is true huh I'm gonna say um talk
man I can't think of a good one uh I'm
not gonna worry about it let's get into
the news man sounds good sounds good
first news topic Thursday night from the
fallout miles Garrett the Cleveland
Browns linebacker is suspended for the
rest of the season and indefinitely
after that after ripping off Mason
Rudolph's helmet and then hitting him
with it you know at during a skirmish at
the end of the game did you see this yep
I saw it man I it was you know I just
thought it was guys being guys out there
I really thought it was like oh it
definitely was out of hand like you
can't it's not fair that he gets a
weapon and he doesn't get a weapon it's
true I think they should you know have
them do it you know you have the guy
have a chance to have a shield or you
know some other let's play a fifth
quarter these didn't think what they
want is a fifth quarter note have been
nice I'd have been nice for four guys
from each team out there with a helmet
and a shield and see who wins it I was
also amazed that not that many people
came to everybody's rescue it seemed
like yeah except marques Pouncy he the
Center for the Pittsburgh he was the one
he liked when
straight hood he was punching and
kicking miles Garrett in the head once
they had him subdued to the ground it
was pretty wild he got suspended three
games and did Rudolph get suspended or
no no he didn't in Rudolph was kind of
tickling him by the neck and stuff did
you see that yeah
Oh Jay Simpson also saw and he really
thought Mason's story you want to hear
Oh Jesu yes minute Mason went after the
man's helmet with his foot in his groin
it's on I'm hearing all these announcers
in the garret should be suspended maybe
you should but one of the guys trying to
get your mind off your head and that's
when it started
white with his foot in your groin it's
on I'm just saying take care well yeah I
mean look Oh Jay also will kill somebody
yeah
so for him it doesn't take much for it
to be on you know what I'm saying dude
if you were married to me it's on you
know uh Wow like you know what I'd
there's something to that I thought it
would have been fair if he got three
games that's what I thought it would
even fair it seemed like the heat of the
heat of of you know the heat of battle
mm-hmm would you think I thought he was
like a complete maniac and I seem like
my guess when it right when it happened
was it was gonna be the rest of the
season suspension
I mean vantes perfect perfect he already
got suspended for the season for the
Raiders earlier just for like helmet
helmet hits and like I don't know he
swung that with kind of ill intent
usually I'm like let him play let him
fight everybody soft but he really
seemed like he just completely lost
control and he needs to be punished I'm
surprised though like a couple weeks ago
he tweeted about he was in his car and a
fan walked up to him and like acted like
they wanted an autograph but then just
hauled off and punched him in the face
mm-hm and he didn't do it he didn't
react at all in that moment so I just
feel like that fan really caught him on
a good day because otherwise he would
have been murdered essentially yeah I
mean it's just like maybe
yeah maybe Rudolph I don't know I mean
that the tough thing too is for Rudolph
is like I don't know if that fueled him
or didn't fuel him you know I guess
we'll see when he plays his next game if
it like fired him up or if it's gonna
like make him more scared I wonder if
that would have any effect and they play
each other in two weeks Oh that'll be a
super interesting yeah oh yeah man it
was nice it was almost like the old days
it was almost like Bill Laimbeer was bad
yeah yeah I love I love the old late 80s
Early 90s basketball fights there were
there were some classics oh yeah I love
that too man yeah I want that fifth
quarter bro yeah let it you know what
I'm saying let's let it all be out there
leave it where it is like you said
everything's turning WWE could get a
Royal Rumble fifth quarter what else we
got so Colin Kaepernick he finally got
his wish and was able to work out in
front of NFL scouts his work out on
Saturday ended up taking place at a high
school in Atlanta the NFL initially
scheduled it for the Atlanta Falcons
practice facility but there was some
back-and-forth with some statements made
from the NFL and Colin Kaepernick side
and Kaepernick side said they and if I
was going to deny all media access at
the Falcons practice facility so they
wanted it to be completely transparent
so everybody could see theoretically how
good he did and yeah there's a lot of
posturing on both sides yeah it felt
like that felt like a lot of posturing
on both sides you know it feels like you
know he'd probably I don't know if he
really feels scorned sometimes with him
it's hard to know if he really feels
scorned or if he you know he's kind of
going out of the limelight now and if
you know they're trying to find a way to
get him back in it and it might not even
be him at this point it could be the his
PR people it's interesting whenever you
get caught up in you become something
that's very public you have a lot of
people chirping in your ear about how
you should behave which you should do
you know I really I wonder I wish I knew
him because you would have a much better
idea of what's really kind of going on
like did he move it so that he could
have every reporter be there so he could
get more press or because he's probably
thinking oh if it's closed then nobody
will know how good I did they can say
whatever I don't know what do you think
yeah I'm just not a huge fan of him say
what you will about the cause but I feel
like if you set him down and really
asked like what are you trying to
accomplish with this like you just get
this long drawn-out answer and the heat
he can't really answer it like what he's
doing this for I think it's kind of like
you like people have gotten in his ear
and he's kind of an empty vessel being
just steered in whichever way is gonna
make the quickest book yeah and I also
heard this is complete hearsay but from
someone who says they know of the
situation that like he didn't really
give a [ __ ] about social justice issue
issues at all and then he started dating
some girl who was really active in that
type of thing and that's when he got all
about it I heard that as well I think I
told you that even was it you that told
me I told you I source clothes with
knowledge course this situation bro
that's what I heard or we just both
heard the same thing um yeah it makes
you wonder because they got paid out
from the NFL it just makes you wonder I
don't know I think the NFL gives a lot
of opportunity to African Americans so I
didn't you know it's mostly African
Americans so I didn't see what they I've
never ever seen what the issue is and
you can't tell me if Mark Jackson was it
was taking a knee teams would get rid of
him he'd he'd have he'd still be a
starting quarterback in this league like
dude they should make him take a knee so
good yeah you know for one quarter I'm
saying bro we need to add more quarters
that's the problem this games too short
we're up to six yeah what else we got
let's see a Seattle police captain was
arrested in an undercover prostitution
sting from his own department the 50 to
53 year old Seattle veteran police
captain Randall Woolery offered $40 to
an undercover officer who was posing as
a prostitute and he was arrested on the
spot
Randall dude if you're Randall bro you
going down that's the truth name seven
[ __ ] Randall's that haven't done
something troublesome
yeah nobody can bro yeah that's crazy
his own sting mm-hmm his own department
staying there trying to strut down some
sex trafficking well I think he should
have been suspicious when there was only
$40.00 I don't know what he's trying to
get but yeah you have more I think
experience with prostitutes in myself
what's $40 gonna get you nowadays
$40 isn't man you're not gonna get much
at all for $40 my toes give that to your
buddy dude and just tell him something
you did it you know $40 you should have
saved the money you parlay that you get
500 and then I can get myself there you
go we might have to talk about gambling
more um let's get one more all right
the gloveless combat sports organization
bare-knuckle fighting championship has
signed social media sensation Iranian
Hulk
his name is Sajjad Gary B hmm
he's a 370 pound bodybuilder and he's 27
years old you know and he's been
expressing an interest in combat sports
for a while and the announcement finally
came during bare-knuckles ninth event
this past Saturday hmm
and he really he has what I've often
referred to as desert fat you know you
get the Kardashians have it Kim
Kardashian has that it's almost like
very organized kind of fat it looks like
like to me this gentleman doesn't look
like as much muscle as it is more of a
gristle more of a you know more of a
hard fat and you can there's you know I
remember I dated a girl for a while that
had that hard fat in her and it's more
of a it feels a little more outdoorsy
then more you get that soft you know
soft fat it just feels a little bit more
like a you know I've said this before
but like a [ __ ] diaper if you feel
somebody [ __ ] diaper out from the
outside of it like a baby's after it's
full and if you kind of squeeze it a
little it feels like that but um but
yeah this looks like that hard fat to me
uh who would this guy fight you to
furniture yeah they're looking for other
super heavyweights
whatever it's not going to be very
high-level boxing once he does get in
there his muscles to me look like that
stuff like you'd see guys they inject it
with something then it it I guess I
guess it's hard hard fat is what you're
calling it but yeah it looks they inject
it and it's not real muscle and it's
like dangerous for you but they get this
look that I guess it's desirable to some
that grow toques man is something yeah
there's something there's a new that's
gonna be the next thing it's just
organized fat you know people are gonna
get tired of doing all this muscle and
at some point it's gonna become more of
a you know there's gonna be more of a
sculpted fat in people like oh look how
cool my fat is you know whereas not just
like look a lot watch my fat be wherever
it wants to be look how I control my fat
look what I did
you know I have a Mount Rushmore on my
back you know like you're gonna be able
to really do whatever you want with a
lot of botoxing and and stuff like that
future is exciting yeah I mean it's
gonna be Wow and especially if this guy
I mean who knows this guy could be
President uh or this guy and and now
some of these camera angles look kind of
snaky here though yeah it definitely
looks like there's some Photoshop often
with a lot of stuff he puts out he looks
like Bluto from the aforementioned
Popeyes yeah yeah he really does that's
good call wow man I couldn't imagine me
in that big now I also wouldn't be
shocked if you walked in and this dude
was [ __ ] a recliner you know he
seemed I kind of dude that he would see
a furniture and get turned out so but
that's beautiful man that desert fat and
it really there's something romantic
about it that's what's going on thanks
Nick good luck on the third date if you
go home one thanks thanks appreciate it
oh right uh I got to go to a meeting
guys and I love you and this is gonna be
y'all today it's gonna be all
what's going on it's November might not
have an episode next week I'm not sure
yet and you can do it and that's it
that's it yeah and everything's gonna be
fine
and and that's it there's not a ton to
think about really but there's a lot to
do so and you can do it so there we go
gang man yeah let's leave out on let's
look about the same we came in with
Spencer Jacob growl and this is
celebrate you guys be good to yourselves
because you deserve it and thank you
[Music]
cellophane is
let's have some fun while we all die